Writing a story isn't easy.
Building one about your business
that captivate your audience and
teaches them the value you
provide is even harder.
Now you have just a few minutes
to pitch your idea, and
it's possible to lose our attention
in the first ten seconds.
So what do you do?
In this lesson, we'll figure that out.
We'll take all the work
you've done thus far and
organize it into a compelling story.
You'll learn how to present the story,
overcome any objections, and
refine your pitch over time.
By the end of this lesson, you'll have
a pitch you can use to help secure
investment, build your team,
and grow your business.
So welcome to the lesson.
You've got an amazing story to tell,
so let's get started writing it.